maman tu descends s'il te plaît tu vas
tomber là il ya un moment devient
vraiment les parents ses parents vous
êtes ses soeurs non sa fille et elle est
logé et nourri blanchi sans même pas
compte
elle est bourrée au nom oui moi on a
quelque chose à vous dire je suis
enceinte
il veut de grands patrons que vous ayez
pas le garder elle a toujours été très
drôle quand est ce que tu vas arrêter de
me faire la gueule et fils unique va
être maintenant qu'est-ce qui est le
plus beau coup ça par exemple tu vas tu
rappeler comment grand moment pourquoi
pas mimie bon ben on va boire un verre
tu seulement recoucher avec mon ex mari
vingt ans après pas vraiment
j'ai ma mère voilà votre mère étant
sorti quoi quoi
enceintes en même temps français
seraient pas banal non vraiment c'est
bravo ouailles sur ça y'a pas de mots
c'est fou d'être aussi mature ok c'est
bon là je la paie j'attends un bébé
c'est pas possible pas aussi bon ben si
si tu peux pas réfléchir de temps en
temps tu as quel âge je t'en veux pas
parce que tu vas avoir un enfant je t'en
veux d'être un enfant
el hammam a des ailes la vie vous laisse
toujours le choix d'en faire un accident
une aventure
et du coup la mère de mon petit fils
sera aussi la soeur de votre enfant
voilà ce qu'on peut